Dos personas parten del mismo punto,
ambos en la misma dirección
y ambos a la misma hora,
a las 9 de la mañana.
Uno de ellos va caminando
mientras que el otro va trotando.
La velocidad promedio
de la persona que va trotando
es 1 km/h más lenta
que el doble de la velocidad promedio
de la persona  que va caminando,
ésta va a ser una de nuestras ecuaciones...
déjame subrayarla...
en dos horas, la persona que va trotando,
está 3 km adelante
de la persona que va caminando.
Aquí tenemos otra ecuación
y después dice,
encuentra la velocidad
de la persona que va trotando.
Y bueno,
lo primero que vamos a hacer,
es escribir esta primera oración
como una ecuación.
Y dice, la velocidad promedio
de la persona que va trotando,
es decir, lo voy a escribir
como "v" subíndice "t",
la velocidad promedio
de la persona que va trotando,
es igual a dos veces, la velocidad de la persona
que va caminando, menos 1 km/h.
Es justo lo que nos dice esta primera oración,
pero aquí ya está escrita en matemáticas,
es decir, que la velocidad promedio
de la persona que trota es 1 km/h más lenta
que la velocidad promedio
de la persona  que camina
y ahora,  la otra oración me dice
que después de 2 horas,
la persona que va trotando está 3 km después
de la persona que va caminando,
esto lo voy a escribir como distancia.
La distancia después
de 2 horas de la persona que va trotando,
es decir, la distancia subíndice "t",
esto va a ser igual a la misma distancia que recorrió
la persona que va caminando,
es decir, "d" subíndice "c", más 3 km.
Y bueno, parece que esto no tiene sentido,
una ecuación habla de velocidad
y la otra de distancia,
de distancia después de 2 horas,
es decir, tenemos un tiempo común.
Y entonces como parece
que tenemos dos ecuaciones muy extrañas,
lo que voy a hacer es recordar
la siguiente fórmula que es muy importante
siempre tenerla a la mano,
hay que recordar que la distancia
es igual a la velocidad
por el tiempo, pero el tiempo
siempre va a ser 2 horas,
porque la segunda ecuación que tenemos,
nos habla de la distancia que recorrieron,
después de dos horas de trayecto.
Y entonces ahora si, utilizando esta información,
voy a cambiar esta ecuación que tengo aquí
y me va a quedar que la distancia
de la persona que va trotando,
es igual a 2 por la velocidad
porque transcurrieron dos horas
y estoy utilizando la fórmula de aquí arriba.
Y de igual manera, si yo tengo
la distancia de la persona que va caminando,
esto es igual a 2 porque son 2 horas,
por la velocidad de la persona que va caminando,
lo único que estoy haciendo,
sustituyendo estos valores de la distancia,
en términos de los valores de la velocidad
utilizando la fórmula que escribí aquí arriba.
Y ahora si, si nosotros ponemos
esta nueva ecuación aquí abajo,
me va a quedar que 2 veces la velocidad
de la persona que va trotando,
pues esto es igual a 2 veces la velocidad
de la persona que va caminando más 3.
Lo único que estoy haciendo, es escribiendo
esta ecuación que tengo aquí a la derecha,
aquí abajo, para que ahora si, utilicemos
algún método para resolver
este sistema de ecuaciones simultáneamente.
Ojo, date cuenta
que lo más importante de este ejercicio,
fue darme cuenta que podíamos escribir a la distancia
en función de la velocidad
utilizando la fórmula de aquí arriba.
Y bueno,
¿cómo resolvemos
este sistema de ecuaciones?
Pues se me ocurre que lo más fácil es multiplicar
esta ecuación de arriba por menos,
la voy a multiplicar todo por -1...
y entonces aquí me queda un menos...
aquí también me queda un menos...
y después -1 por -1 es lo mismo que 1 positivo,
o más 1.
Y ahora sí, ya tengo dos ecuaciones
y se van a cancelar estas 2,
entonces si yo sumo ambos lados de la ecuación,
del lado izquierdo me queda,
menos la velocidad
de la persona que va trotando
más 2 veces la velocidad
de la persona que va trotando,
pues solamente me queda
la velocidad de la persona que va trotando,
una vez esa velocidad,
estos dos se cancelan
y después me queda 1 más 3,
1 más 3 es 4
y ya está
y ademas está de lujo,
porque era justo lo que me pedían,
encuentra la velocidad de la persona que va trotando.
La velocidad de la persona
que va trotando, son 4 km/h,
sin embargo si también quisiéramos
la velocidad de la persona que va caminando,
entonces vamos a sustituir este valor
en la ecuación de arriba,
que la ecuación de arriba
originalmente se veía así,
la velocidad de la persona que va trotando,
es iguala dos veces la velocidad de la persona
que va caminando menos 1,
si sustituimos el valor de la velocidad
que va trotando,
me quedaría que 4 es igual a
2 "v" subíndice "c" menos 1,
sumando 1 de ambos lados,
después dividiendo entre 2,
me quedaría que "v" subíndice "c"
es igual a 5/2 km/h.
La velocidad promedio de la persona
que va caminando es de 2.5 km/h,
sin embargo ésta
es la respuesta de mi problema.